it's shortly before dawn and the working
day is beginning for Ingo Sheila he has
a job but he's not sure for how long
there's a growing number of cheap
foreign competitors on the roads
customers are turning more and more to
them come on yeah when you drive into
the truck park here at VW almost
everyone driving car transporters is
Czech polish or Lithuanian if you look
at the container transport in Hamburg
you can see a lot of Eastern Europeans
there some respected companies have gone
out of business because they're too
expensive to get contracts this is the
Baltic port of Taba Minda the ferries
landing here every day bring trailers
from Scandinavia German transporters
don't have much of a chance they often
leave the port empty-handed the Eastern
European competition gets the jobs the
drivers camp out in their trucks at the
side of the road until the telephone
rings the contracts have gone to the
Eastern Europeans once again they'll
haul the Scandinavian trailers down to
France and Spain and they'll do it at a
price that Western European truckers
can't match
the Omni mode the arm we've got the road
tolls and the cost of fuel and
maintenance those are set costs and the
company can't cut those the only place
the company can save money is on wages I
mean it'll cost but drivers are now
taking action over the unequal
conditions between Eastern and Western
Europe English woods has started
organizing demonstrations at the
beginning of the year today he's planned
a convoy through Lubeck around 50
truckers from Germany Denmark and the
Netherlands are taking part ladies and
gentlemen before we set off just a few
rules we're from the police will lead
with this car here and the other car
will go at the rear the trucker's are
worried about the future the German
logistics industry is also worried by
developments via Vasant spice we know
for example that in Bulgarian Romania
the new EU members hourly wages of 2 to
3 euros are normal the salary in the
Baltic countries is between 500 and 600
euros that would be absolutely
unacceptable in Germany it's way below
even a minimum wage
the convoy through Lubeck has arrived at
an industrial estate the Latvian
transport company Dino trans has a Depot
here rumor has it that the company is
hiring Filipino drivers at only 600
euros a month the truckers want to be
heard but the managers of Dino trans
refused to speak on camera he's got
something to hide if he won't come out
here and tell us what's going on it's a
case for Brussels but it seems these
developments have caught the politicians
napping the trucker's have invited a
European parliamentarian she's come to
listen to what the drivers have to say
join the union strong unions represent
your interests the trucker's want a
minimum wage to apply in Eastern Europe
- it's not on the agenda as far as
truckers are concerned but we have to
act because an industry could die off in
Europe and that could have catastrophic
consequences for the future which is why
the trucker's are increasing the
pressure
I'm pretty happy with the turnout but
I'm really happy with the convoy
a convoy like this really attracts
attention the next demonstrations are
already being planned and if that
doesn't work
the trucker's say they'll start blocking
the highways